this is my culture if i can't embrace
how my hair grows from my scalp how can
i embrace myself i can embrace where
i've come from
i'm not averse to relaxing my hair i
know it's obviously like a
political subject and people like really
against it
but a lot of my friends who work in like
corporate companies
they can't wear their hair a certain way
or they have to wear it wear a weave or
something because it's not seen as
professional eurocentric beauty
standards have historically deemed afro
hair as
unattractive and unprofessional but does
society and the black community itself
still have a hard time accepting natural
hair
my name is serge i'm a filmmaker from
london
but i was born in the congo when i was
younger
some of my friends at school had their
hair braided in cornrows but i couldn't
because as my dad made clear we don't do
that in our culture
so it was strictly a level one or two
trim with a skin fade
but these decisions are far from trivial
to understand the significance of black
hair i began by exploring its roots
in history for centuries black
communities around the world
have created hairstyles that are
uniquely their own
but the slave trade changed everything
one of the methods that the slave
masters used was to try to dehumanize
the individuals that they were enslaving
one of those things was to categorize
them
the light of the skin the easier the
hair was to manage
in western terms it's been at the root
of
a lot of discrimination after
the abolition of slavery when people
wanted to get into
getting work even as a musician they
couldn't walk past without
having to go through the pencil test if
in a big
musical hall at the entrance they'll be
told if you want to pass
this pencil has to be put through your
hair and if it falls to the ground
you can come in if it gets stuck you
can't come in
so without saying if you're black you
can't come in
they would say if it's in direct wales
then if you haven't got european
straight hair you're not coming in and
while
some struggles of black hair are based
in history others go back to our first
experiences of black hair
in childhood and why did you come into
it
i to get my son's hair done so what's it
like having
to do a black son's hair
it takes time it took me a while to
learn
but just watching other people really
you've got to support that fro haven't
you
i hated getting my hair done it was um
you see my baby pictures everyone laughs
at me and say look chris what the hell
was going on with your hair i just
you know heard it you know the shave
will come into my my head and i just
lost it i just remember crying and
crying
my first ever memory of my hair was just
sitting in between my sister's legs
and like holding tight while she came
with my hair so
tight i don't remember my natural hair's
young child i realized that was the
starting point for me
not viewing my hair as good hair by the
time i'm 17 i've got
a throw in and i've got a comb in an
afro
walking around just trying to like a
self-representation trying to find
yourself
minstrel shows in the 19th century
mocked the hair texture of black people
comparing it to all and often describing
it as
nappy to be accepted in society
and to achieve a higher social status
some women began to straighten their
hair
so what is it like to have your hair
chemically relaxed
it's kind of like a form of
self-degradation you're burning
your scalp to the point you've got scabs
in your hair to make your hair straight
to fit in with this western
um concept of beauty i think i was like
19 or something
and like literally like most of my hair
on like my left and right
temple had gone i'd used like a relaxer
that had literally like just
burnt all the way through you have to
get like retouches
and then your scalp starts to burn and
you get like little saws
i was just starting out swimming and she
was like it's probably the easiest way
for me to
look after it she'd relax it then braid
it so it lasts for like six weeks it's
hard to
ignore the pressures of like wanting to
look good like day to day
relaxers are made up of chemicals like
sodium hydroxide
that destroy kinks in the hair and leave
a straightened look
in the 1980s and 90s relaxers became the
norm
and images of black women on television
and magazines
usually featured straight relaxed hair
but things are changing and many women
are now embracing their natural locks
thanks to a new wave of the natural hair
movement
this is clarissa mcdonald founder of
curly by nature
she runs workshops encouraging women to
embrace their natural hair
just by the definition of relaxing the
hair you're destroying the hair so
you're damaging the hair so relaxed hair
essentially is in a damaged state
because the bones
of the hair is broken down i hate my
natural hair
like i don't like people seeing me with
my natural hair like even my friends
i'll hide from them from like seeing me
with my hair out i always like to have
like
weave in or like extensions my
last partner will be like oh just take
off your wig like it's
it's comfortable sleeping without wig
but because i didn't like myself i
wouldn't
see me without a wig so sometimes he'll
be asleep or something
and i'll run to the bathroom put my
headscarf on and run back in bed if i
know he's
about to wake up i'll go back and put my
wig on
[Laughter]
the whole natural hair journey
the natural hair movement actually
emerged in the 1960s when sporting afro
became a symbol of black power
self-love and solidarity within the
black community
this was a time when black people were
still fighting for basic human rights
like
equal employment voter rights and
integrated public facilities
we all have choices and you know you can
wear your hair natural
you can have your hair in protective
styles and decide to wear weaves and
wigs
you can relax your hair if you so choose
having natural hair isn't easier but for
me
it's better you know i've probably been
guilty of times of saying ah
i don't like weave why are these women
wearing weave and they need to take the
weave out
when it comes to going natural the next
hurdle black people face
is in the workplace for years there have
been too many cases of black employees
and applicants
denied employment or promotion because
of the way they chose to wear their hair
so when i first started working at my
company i wore a wig for three years
and when i decided to then sort of
embrace my natural hair and just go to
a work environment and and be natural i
was aware that i was making a political
statement
i would not wear my hair out to work
just because it's big
particularly if you're going to work
places that predominantly white
um then you do feel like you need to
conform and you need to look like
everybody else that works there you
don't want anything that makes you stand
out you know your hair must be
you know trimmed cut low and etc but
then i'm seeing colleagues of mine with
long hair
blonde or whatever it might be and
there's no mention of how they should
keep their hair
and i feel like i wouldn't be taking
that seriously if i had blonde hair like
this in office and i'm going into a
meeting with say
a partner and a high net with clients
i a lot of us unfortunately a lot of
black women turn ourselves down in the
corporate world
however i get to a point where i feel
like i don't have to
historically advertisements reinforce
the notion
that natural afro features were inferior
it's no wonder then that some of these
negative perceptions
still linger for me growing up
there were very few role models so i
think i struggled for
a bit as a child and as a team whenever
i went to like a wedding
or somewhere nice i was straight on my
hair i thought straight hair was the the
epitome of beauty
and i just thought to myself why is it
when i'm going somewhere nice
i feel that my own kinky hair isn't
beautiful it comes from media it comes
from films we grew up with
and like most of the women we look at
growing up are white women i think now
it's starting to change a little bit you
see more kind of black women with their
natural hair on magazines
you see them all on tv even though you
don't see
i don't think there's like a complete
representation but what is being done to
celebrate afro-hair in the media
to find out i caught up with leckia lay
the founder of project embrace
project embrace is a platform that was
established to
challenge the narrow perception of what
it means to be beautiful especially to
have beautiful hair
and generally in the media especially in
advertising
black women are almost non-existent and
that's when i decided i would do a
billboard campaign
clear channel got back to me and said
it's a worthy campaign we're going to
support you
when they said they're giving me um
billboards in seven cities
i was besides myself i wanted just one
billboard in london and they're giving
me seven billboards
wow by looking back at the struggles and
pressures black people have faced
throughout history
it's clear to see why self hair love can
be a journey
here i'll come to discover is as much
about self-expression
as it is about self-identity and
cultural representation
no matter what we decide to do with our
hair the most important thing is to
embrace it
because ultimately accepting your hair
is sort of accepting yourself
we basically want every young black girl
to feel confident we identified that
when we're not we had we struggled with
identity
no matter how much we try to enhance
what god's given us naturally is always
going to be better
we can't expect great things from our
young people and teenagers if we
are telling them they're not good enough
we're all perfectly imperfect
whatever it is whether it's your weight
your complexion
your hair you just gotta embrace it and
i'm saying this is you you can't expect
someone to love you if you don't love
yourself and you have to know yourself
to love yourself
[Music]
you